okay guys Abby is on her way up West Ham
drew nil-nil it wolves stop that are you
guys changing your personalities for
Abby she's here yet
Tsubasa's you are married okay this is
exactly the kind of male douchebaggery
that is about to take a real hit around
here don't you know I'm talking about a
femme elution Tracy Chapman she's a
woman right it's a new era at TGS let's
see the blogosphere try to say that I
hate women now look at all these dude I
knew I smelled sausage yes Abbi I'm Liz
thank you just touched I did it mine are
different sizes Abbi these are the
writers Oh where's little Abbi gonna
[__] guess I'll have to sit on somebody
laughs it's a bear he's gone
[Music]
if we strength Oh Oprah I'm gonna set
the new woman you hired just that I'm
not wearing any underwear you should be
careful around the crew New York gives
us a tax break from employing sex
offenders terrible program what is that
that is Abby Flynn she's a guest writer
she's being hot and doing baby talk I
invented that summer of 98 I took it to
a whole new level there can't be two of
us Liz she must be destroyed no Jenna
that is exactly the problem men
infantilize women and women tear each
other down exactly I'll start by
spreading a destructive rumor about her
like the famous one I made up about
Jamie Lee Curtis that she has two months
look you and I actually want the same
thing but we're not gonna destroy Abby
we're gonna fix her yes
like you fix a dog well sterilize her no
I'm gonna show Abby that she doesn't
need to act like this
[Laughter]
you